hello everyone the question which I want
to address today is is it still worth
studying mechanical engineering in the
third decade of the 21st Century
well at the very outset I want to make
it clear that hardcore engineering
departments like mechanical engineering
civil engineering and electrical
engineering and a number of others they
are absolutely essential
that they form the real basis of the
actual infrastructure of a Nation
and so from that point of view there are
absolutely worth studying but then the
thing is
in this modern day and age people are
naturally very selfish they have been
they are self-oriented so I do not
expect that students are going to make
their personal career choices based on
or keeping national interests in mind
that is not going to happen that's
completely unrealistic so people are of
course students are of course going to
make their personal career choices
keeping their own self-centered interest
in mind
that is fine so the real question which
we want to answer here is is it still
worth studying mechanical from the point
of view of personal happiness so what I
mean by that so happiness in the context
of a job it uh it it is of course
associated with the job satisfaction
things like does it pay well do you get
a high salary do you get some kind of a
job satisfaction from the point of view
of the like the intellectual
satisfaction what you're doing on a
day-to-day basis and of course uh
whether there is any chance for good
amount of growth in your career so
uh let's let's consider these things
well first of all regarding the high pay
uh let us not get into
some of the murky details of high pay
which some people have an absolutely
wrong notion regarding High pay in this
in the sense of crores so those things
uh there there's completely wrong
Notions about it because sometimes what
happens is that you get some foreign pay
in a foreign currency and people just
like
completely in a very naive and stupid
way I'm sorry to say this they just
convert it into Indian rupees and then
they say it's it's in crores without
even thinking about the about the
purchasing power that entails uh in the
context of where they will be located so
I'm not talking about those things but
High pay in the sense like my personal
opinion of haipei is that
your pay should be high enough if I have
to say it's a high pay so that uh things
like price rise uh inflation these kinds
of things do not directly affect your
day-to-day consumption so you do not
have to change the level of what you eat
and how you live the small luxuries of
life based on these price changes this
Lux these price fluctuations I mean you
are aware of it but it doesn't affect
you directly it doesn't affect your
family if that is so then your pay is
high enough
there is another thing that uh slightly
more subtle that your pay should be high
enough I I'd say a pay is high enough if
you can afford some of the common
Comforts of a Modern Life uh
and not just afford it if something goes
wrong I mean these are like engineering
things things go wrong maybe the the
refrigerator breaks down or those things
happen uh if those if such kind of
things happen you do not have to worry
uh that okay again I have to save up
money to replace them if it happens you
can address it directly so if you if you
are in that kind of a financial
situation your pay is high enough so I
think this is a good enough definition
at least from an Indian Point of View
now we are of course not talking about
your pay is high enough that you can go
every year on a European Vacation so not
that kind of high so from this Viewpoint
yes mechanical engineering will afford
you to get jobs uh which may not be
extremely high paying but it will it
will enable you to leave more or less
such a comfortable kind of life okay but
as I said
people are not satisfied by those things
only so there's that the other thing is
that the intellectual satisfaction
well there is a huge amount of technical
like hardcore technicalities involved in
in a core job
but there is a flip side to it also
which people absolutely have to
understand is that uh and I will
elaborate on this a little bit more uh
you see mechanical engineering has been
in existence since I mean if you if you
really think about it since forever but
in the modern form at least for 150
years 200 years let's say I mean if you
have if you have to draw a line let's
say
um
the the Industrial Revolution okay it's
a very very rough kind of estimate but
let's say 150 years 200 years so during
this process it has matured a lot
now the the absolutely the modern and
The Cutting Edge kind of engineering
that is there that goes on
you really have to know a lot to be able
to contribute meaningfully to that
which means that if you have done only
your bachelors in mechanical engineering
or maybe Civil Engineering you will be
able to do some kind of technical job
but it will not be at that high level
which may perhaps give you a kind of
intellectual satisfaction which is
associated with some kind of really
creative work
okay you just do not have that knowledge
just after four years of a bachelor's to
be able to contribute at that level
every engineering firm understands this
and please understand that a hardcore
engineering firm in these domains
mechanical civil electrical
those kinds of things are they involve
uh stuff on which people's lives may be
at stake it is not a website okay uh I
mean of course if a website breaks down
like a banking website then it can cause
uh like tremendous hardship like loss of
property loss of wealth but it directly
doesn't affect anyone's life like nobody
dies directly because if a website fails
or if some kind of a or an application
fails but if a mechanical engineering
system fails if a civil engineering
system fails it can directly cause
people's death so
the fact that you do not have sufficient
experience is actually a thing to be
really really careful about so you'll
not be directly allowed to work on
certain things just after a master's
degree
um
regarding growth
well because it is such a mature thing
um
there is a tremendous amount of growth
possible because there is so much like a
verticality involved in the technology
you start very low
if you keep on grinding and if you keep
on getting involved with higher and
higher levels of technology and if you
can if you can upgrade your education ah
Maybe by going through a Masters program
then certainly you can rise higher up in
the technical ranks that is absolutely
possible and that can be a source of
immense satisfaction also
now there is some something
um
well I have to I have to say it as a
negative point is that see when you
start out in these kinds of very
traditional classical Fields mechanical
civil as a very low level engineer
without the proper experience
then necessarily you will be assigned to
those kinds of roles which are kind of
Maintenance as I've already said you
will never be asked to design something
from scratch I mean there may be very
few exceptions to these but this is the
general Norm without the experience
you'll always be confined to some kind
of a maintenance kind of thing or some
kind of routine things
now
uh
in most firms the maintenance kind of
work is not very attractive it's grind
work okay but you cannot go to a higher
rank without going through that without
going through that grind work
there is also the other thing that uh
the computer science technology it is
not very old so there is a lot of
opportunity for a starter uh for for a
person who has just finished his
Bachelors to contribute some amount I
mean contribute significantly more
creative work compared to a mechanical
engineering beginner guide
uh
I have not touched up in a certain point
which is that if you go to a good enough
College maybe the iits even the nits
then uh mechanical engineering graduates
I know this for a fact because I'm in
one they end up in quite high paying
jobs like really high paying jobs
impressive jobs but they are not in the
hardcore domain these are intelligent
guys various kinds of firms
non-engineering firms they realize this
and they take these guys in various
kinds of non-engineering roles but it's
absolutely fabulous in those kinds of
things maybe in consultancy maybe in
finance where they just need some smart
people uh now don't ask me what is the
basis of this shouldn't they be taking
some kind of a finance major or an
economics major for those kinds of jobs
I don't know what goes on through their
mind they need smart people they get the
smart people from the various
departments irrespective to the
Departments and they're fine with it so
mechanical engineering guys do end up
getting fabulous jobs at least the
placement statistics here in our
department are quite good okay
the question which I want to go back to
is is if the if the technology is really
so very mature in mechanical engineering
is there really some kind of an
opportunity for a creative work
so so here I'm trying to go a little bit
from the hardcore engineering job to
maybe the research and development side
and uh it is true okay so there has been
so much work done over the last 150
years 200 years that in order to be able
to do something creative you necessarily
have to do your Masters and if you
really have to reach the highest level
the absolute Cutting Edge level then you
have to do your PhD Okay so
there you have it this is the this is
the Stark Truth uh and I have seen uh
PhD students after after after doing
their defense they do get absorbed in
these uh in the in the research
divisions of very hardcore engineering
firms
so what what kind of opportunities are
there in mechanical engineering at the
absolute Cutting Edge level so some
people uh may be thinking that
mechanical engineering is ultimately IC
engines internal combustion engines that
is patently not true it is a very
important component but that is not all
there is to it uh in The Cutting Edge or
at The Cutting Edge my mechanical
engineering involves a lot of or it has
a contribution in a lot of
interdisciplinary areas for example in
biomedical engineering you cannot
imagine the kind of innovative and
exciting things that are there that a
hardcore mechanical engineer has to do
uh to to really bring up the technology
in the biomedical or the bioengineering
field similarly in areas like uh Soft
Robotics in areas involving various
kinds of electrochemical and electric
chem chemical mechanical systems and
certainly the more traditional
electromechanical systems mechanical
engineers have a tremendous role to play
similarly there is a lot of
opportunities in in developing various
kinds of innovative things for the
defense industry
uh even in the traditional areas suppose
an engineering firm has to set up has to
be set up and industry has to be set up
uh in those kinds of situations even if
you do not have to go for any kind of
interdisciplinary thing the very fact
that in a completely new environment uh
you have to set up something completely
new it means that uh the the the
traditional knowledge has to be applied
in a very very Innovative way uh in a
new environment and that that calls for
a lot of expertise a lot of
uh like Cutting Edge thinking uh in this
modern day and age
so unless you get into those kinds of
nitty-gritty details you will not be
able to appreciate the the level at
which this this real engineering game is
played but then again as a beginner you
may not be able to be involved in those
things you will need to go through the
grind to to pick up that experience
so uh
to Circle back to that original question
is it worth studying mechanical
engineering
you see
my answer is yes okay you may think that
I have been myself a mechanical
engineering student I am now a
mechanical engineering faculty at IIT
kharagpur so of course I'm going to say
yes but I have pointed out certain
negative aspects of it and the most
negative aspect if you really want to
call it negative is that the if you have
to do something creative you have to
first gather the experience so you have
to have the patience to learn you have
to have the humility to learn from
others to build up that experience level
to reach a certain point in your career
so that you start contributing in a very
creative fashion if you if you think
that from day 0 you are going to be able
to uh come up with fantastic engineering
Solutions on your own it doesn't happen
like that this is not a computer program
that you can just write up on your own
get a result and be fancy about it
like hardcore engineering involves
setting up
uh things which are a mature reflection
of a long Legacy of development
in order to contribute to that you have
to work as part of a very large team
dealing with very very hard and concrete
things which
involves a lot of investment of money
time and effort like you as an
individual engineer will not be able to
say that I own this engineering system
it doesn't happen like that it's always
a collective ownership
so anything serious anything which is
Meaningful anything which is substantial
you can be very much a part of it if you
study mechanical engineering but then
you will have to have that patience that
humility and that maturity to be able to
really understand that yes this is an
engineering system this is this is
Hardcore concrete and this is something
you're going to build which will last
for years and years
and finally a a word of advice is that
uh
if you're a school student and you love
mechanics and physics
there is no reason for you not to take
up mechanical engineering but at the
same time it comes with a warning that
when you were relatively young and you
have not been exposed to various
Temptations in life it is very easy to
think that yes you love mechanical and
that you love mechanics and physics and
therefore mechanical engineering is the
right choice for you and maybe you get
swayed by some of your elders saying
things like mechanical engineering is
Evergreen therefore you must take it and
you do end up taking it
um I think you need to have some second
thoughts about it also because when you
as you keep on growing up and you see
people around you uh maybe studying for
four years and then getting for and then
going for some kind of a fabulous job uh
maybe if there's from some other uh
Department like a circular Department uh
that initial love for mechanics and
physics may not be strong enough for you
to
to maybe ditch your department
Okay so
many people suffer through these kinds
of disillusionments many many students
suffer through this okay because
ultimately when it comes to doing
something which you absolutely love
the core values which are there inside
you that will come to the Forefront okay
I am turning a little bit philosophical
here but this is we are talking about
life and carrier here so I have to be a
little bit like this
um
so uh and and see we are a lot of us uh
in in India we are from
a middle class background where what
others say influence our thinking and
our decision making a lot so if if you
are prone to those kinds of influences
then uh
please understand that maybe you have to
upgrade your maturity uh
or
maybe you have to end up doing something
else which you originally do not love
uh so
my answer to the question is it worth
studying mechanical is of course yes a
capital letter s y a s but with certain
caveats and certain subtleties okay so
my only hope is that uh if you're a
young student
who have who has already taken up
mechanical uh maybe having second
thoughts about it ah don't be too
worried
okay don't be too worried there are
always job opportunities here and if you
are a school student who is thinking of
taking a mechanical or maybe maybe
getting Anchorage to take up mechanical
um
think about it whether you'll be able to
maintain your love and go through the
grind of uh really building up your
experience because
ultimately when you're over a certain
curve over a certain point uh
you will be able to do something
absolutely fabulous and exciting
Okay so
there you have it
so thank you very much and all the best